hi i'm ryan right and i'm gerry welcome
two reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and not to Sea World War
see let's turn reason to see number one
saw me thrills there are zombies in this
movie there are several several million
zombies in his booth you know what's
impressive is they managed to make a
pg-13 zombie apocalypse film go around
the world and make it actually pretty
entertaining and not distracting that's
not rated aren't full of blood and gore
and stuff action is so vicious and yet
rabid that it feels intense anyway and
like violent stuff happens just
sometimes the camera doesn't fully like
you know zoom in on it or something yeah
like bits and pieces of it like they're
like oh it's the corner of the shot
right there yeah I see that person's
hand hacked off you know yeah I was like
this is brutal enough to be rated art
it's just your dad you're just you know
what's happening you're just not fully
seeing it what's cool is that this is a
zombie movie and the best parts are the
zombie stuff there's plenty of it and in
the end of movie you know it's it's like
drama zombie drama zombies chama zombies
it's perfect you know if you're not into
the drama you're gonna be into the
zombie sub so there's enough there to
sustain you for the two hours as film is
well and the zombie chaos is very like
pakka lytic yes verdict a nasty yeah
that's like free for all people are
running their zombie there were people
are shooting stuff they're screaming
these are the fastest zombies I've ever
seen the undead it run really fast but
there's the question there is it where
did they don't know where it started so
maybe it's a virus maybe it's not a
zombie at all yeah that makes a marathon
runner yeah I thought that was cool cuz
it because they scramble like rats like
let me get to the food let me guess
oh yeah exactly that's it I thought that
was a cool you know take of kuwait ya
know it was awesome the one thing that
made me worried was that they were so
you know so much visual effects with
zombies because what makes a great
zombie movie a lot of time is the
awesome [ __ ] makeup yeah and you get
some of that in this movie too but you
know for the most part when you're doing
like a crazy world wide saw me movie
they managed to pull it off pretty well
like I wasn't distracting it was cool a
lot of the time is I still thought the
best moments of the zombies were when
they were in makeup effects yeah that's
when they were at their scariest because
that's when it's like really real
looking and that's in stuff it's not
shown trade ya got that put your right
so it's a surprise one thing I like to
and Jeremy Jahns actually pointed this
out did he was how they call him they
call them zombies in this phone and a
lot of movies and shows will call them
something else got like walking dead
calls and walkers and lockers and
fighters yeah yeah and infected exactly
later but in this movie they're like
notes zombie Koreans on the email yeah
well they said it and in this day and
age you kind of would say that I think
yeah definitely it's like well they're
doing exactly what we know from zombie
movies in present day it's like you have
all that pop culture to just be like you
know why they're zombies like we can't
explain Cassie though it's very stupid
to make a present a movie about having
millions of Americans already having see
a bunch of zombie flicks yeah so yeah
good zombie thrills for a pg-13 flake
for sure reason to see number two red
pit honey there's how he says it like
every yeah honey honey running with
someone honey i plus his daughter's name
is Connie yeah no rapids cool in this
movie I like the way they really set up
this guy's character he's a very
believable father to this family very
sympathetic and at the same time you
feel that sense of yeah he really does
give a [ __ ] it's family yeah well he
wants them to death and the way they
leverage him into going on the whole
adventure of the movie is pretty
believable in the in the context of the
time you know cuz it's very good yes and
they give hints up his backstory you
could feel that he did do his homework
on that yeah well he wasn't just some
like dad's on some mission
yeah then hey you get over here E you
look muscular we're sending you out what
was cool about Brad Pitt was it wasn't
distracting to see Brad Pitt the one of
the biggest movie stars in the world in
a Samba movie he really believes
everything that's going on he was
perfectly cast yeah is it a good job he
elevates the movie and he makes almost
every scene he's in like enticing to
watch and definitely could feel so much
thoughts and emotion going through him
without him having the same thing yeah I
mean you can really tell the stakes when
ya can relieve the danger because he
doesn't know if he's gonna get out a lot
of these situations and he's just doing
what he can with what he has you know
and that's yeah it's not a
two-dimensional performance of like oh
I'm scared in this see I'm cool and it
seemed like there's always a sense of
like he has to do what he has to do but
he at the same time there's a lot of
fear resonating with inside this guy
like this guy is probably dealt with a
lot of [ __ ] hitting fans yeah before
reason to see number three the directing
and cemetery after quantum of solace I
was a little bit concerned and I'm glad
this wasn't like handheld craziness type
of movie you know they really knew when
to make the right shots were smooth and
went to be handheld it was a cool
effects they had going on throughout and
the tone was awesome i love the tongue
yeah the tony already there is a very
sort of you know apocalyptic tone in a
very sort of not quite 70s but there's
there is a very sort of dark rabid
zombie tone that they've kind of hold on
to the whole time that i thought was
really good and I'm happy for marc
forster because yeah it's like a quantum
this movie had trouble getting made and
you know I kind of get the sense that
he's a little over his head with these
big blockbusters but this one turned out
a lot better than quasi solid it's and
the way the action is directed works
much better in this world yeah definite
doesn't James Bond what I will say is
like it's a solid blockbuster thriller
when you look at like summer what are
you looking for something that's just
entertaining and this film is you know
it doesn't exactly break new ground or
anything yeah but it is an entertaining
blockbuster film that starts one of the
biggest stars in the world they
succeeded on doing that yeah and it's
but the cool thing to to me was that
it's a blockbuster film that doesn't
feel like every other block
removing yes it's not like you know
speio you got your star trek is you big
adventure and hire men big adventure and
there's a certain snap-snappy to do you
know it's not a horror movie per se
because it's not all that scary both
science-fiction thriller yeah but it
does have that sort of horror tone
absolutely which I thought it definitely
sort of just sets it apart a little bit
from the other yeah and it's fast paced
ooh that's what I liked about it too
it's it's not one of those films that
tries to create tension by it's not at
everything super slow and there's not a
draggy two hours yeah definitely i likey
because in the first 10 minutes they're
like oh my god everything's happening
already yeah exactly one and that's cool
because it does feel like on a normal
day oh my god oh yeah judo in the finale
to I thought there's some great
cinematography there's some awesome
cinematography in this film from the
scenes in Jerusalem that they shown the
trailer with alone all the piles of
zombies happening and when they're in
Korea they're going back to the plane
you know like everyone's kind of in the
dark in the shadows there was a
nightmare sequence that shot really need
in that finale when they're looking for
the UH
that's when it felt the most like a
zombie movie to me it was at that
particular point it out and that was
cool it's a I don't think I've ever seen
a zombie blockbuster has ever been such
a thing uh not on this scale I mean I
don't think on this scale because like
part of the grippe some people been
having is you could make literally 200
zombie movies for the cost of this one
zombie oh yeah you know cuz a lot of the
point you know is being low budget cuz
that's something you can do lots of
carnage with usually you don't want to
have a big star and stuff like that so
this is a different beast in the sense
that it is your first sort of big zombie
blockbuster of that kind what I do have
to ask myself is why did this cost so
much [ __ ] money yeah I saw I'm like
there's some scenes oh my god you see
why that scene cost a lot of money I was
watching you why it's so expensive for
what reason yeah I mean it does to be in
the world and part of what's cool about
it I think is that it it gets both the
global zombie yeah it doesn't make place
just in a city or a small group of
people they really go across the globe
yeah you get a lot of cities that are
being ravaged by these you know
creatures and stuff like that and then
you also have just a global scale and
then you also get scenes where you get
that very intimate sore old-school
zombie filled ones like freedom through
hallways and they're everywhere yeah so
it kind of runs the gamut of types of
zombie scenarios which is cool you know
that's what I like the finale in the
first act because that's when I felt the
most like a zombie movie to me and yeah
that's what I thought it was actually at
its best when the zombie movie feels
like a zombie proofreading was when it's
at its best reason to see number four
Matthew Fox he's in it he pissing in
this movie he might have to squint you
have to not have to do the Brad Pitt
squint did I know it towards the end of
the movie I was like is that Matthew Fox
who has not spoken one string this week
yeah when he first showed up I don't
want to give it away oh yeah it's more
of a where's waldo game with this guy I
remember seen him going next that's
gotta be Matthew Fox and then he's later
on in the movie would like one more
scene and really
yup it's matthew [ __ ] yeah but then you
ever gets like a close up for anything
so you're not entirely sure yeah it's
weird and it calls attention to him in
the in the opposite way cuz you only see
him in wide shots yeah so you're like
wait a minute Matthew [ __ ] why aren't
they focusing on them sound like it's
basically an extra I feel like you got
all of his scenes cut out or something
like that yeah he's a reason to see
because it's a fun game to play when
you're trying to spot him yeah exactly
where's Matthew 5 reasons not to see
craziest [ __ ] is in the trailer yeah if
you've seen any of the trainers yeah
pretty much the best money shots are are
in the trailer you know there's some
good shots throughout the stuff that
made you go oh my god I gotta watch this
movie is pretty much in the trailer it's
not like the whole movie is blown if
you've seen the trailer but like all
that crazy stuff where they're clawing
all over each other that's pretty much
from one scene yeah one chunk of the
movie and a lot of Act one is amazed
just act one but all there's a lot of
thrills in Act one and it kind of dude
give a little too much away yeah and you
know they get they tease at the airplane
sequence it's basically like here's the
setup and then a bunch of crazy [ __ ]
from right in the middle yeah like we
will be where maybe don't watch the
trailer a hundred times before you go
yeah because I guess I saw the trailer
so many times and it made it a little
easy to predict stuff but what I will
say was even though i was watching
certain scenes that had thrills that
were early on i wasn't going away I I'm
okay I'm cool because they haven't shown
this scene yet come we forget about it
because I get so pulled into the thrills
that I would forget about oh that
awesome seeing the trailer that I saw
his trailer is kind of sports let so
much but then again what trailer doesn't
these days have steel man of steel that
doesn't run a lot no it doesn't explode
like one long drama with two action
scenes boy were we wrong yeah right it
was one long action scene with another
drama a little bit of drama split
decisions lacks compelling drama yeah
the reason why i thought the drum the
reason but I thought the drama was I
mean I don't really know why the drama
lack to be honest I just didn't feel the
effective at all because the first act I
thought was great you know you sent up
this family it kind of feels like War of
the Worlds acceptance of aliens as
zombies
it's very personal you believe this
family together and you really care
about them and their go and running
through the cities and stuff like that
and it was all very awesome and but then
when the actual plot kicks in like a
military plot and the mission and stuff
like that I was on board with it I was
watching it but I didn't that's when I
thought the compelling drama just
started lacking and I was only finding
it truly gravitating when the rasam be
stuff happening I guess that's fair i
mean i thought all the actors did a good
job and i was i was pulled in throughout
like i was never bored during any of the
more dramatic scenes and i was always at
least you know along with okay where are
we going next like what's gonna solve
this mystery you know like how are we
gonna combat the zombie hordes I'm not
gonna say it's the most compelling movie
I've seen all year but I was always
pulled into it when I feel like you have
such good drama in the beginning but
then it becomes more about the mission
and stuff which is fine but you know
what makes what I think that would like
for zombie films and stuff i think it's
why people love the walking dead so much
because there's great drama in marc
forster could have learned a little
something from a television show for
this 1i me he's done drama before but
machine gun preacher that and that's the
one he's now yep that's the one not the
one you want an oscar for the only thing
that kind of pulled me out was the fact
that brad pitt has the most conveniently
horrible luck in the world yes it's like
wherever he goes a big disaster happens
where there wasn't one happening already
you know this i can almost every other
scene actually yeah it's like don't come
here dude because every time you go
anywhere bad [ __ ] happens like staying
cooking good luck chuck he'll go to a
place where they're like oh no we were
safe and we we found a way to you know
live peacefully and then all of a sudden
it's like the second he gets there the
[ __ ] zombies any he looks like a kind
of a slow runner but he can outrun every
single zombie in this film tip his hair
it's a Syria it's just the wind it needs
to get runner this is brad pitt's weird
air Vidya reactor is one weird hair
movie yeah I mean Brad Pitt is
indestructible he's Brad Pitt me it's
not as crazy as like a good day to die
hard where you're like the impossible no
but there are certain times were you
like he probably would be dead yeah but
then but then
the weird thing is the reason why this
is part of this what citizens like when
he actually does get injured at points
you're like oh please yeah I believe
that he's really hurt I mean he does get
injured a plenty of times for it to be
believable enough fingers I forget the
character's name now I apologize but I
did think that the Israeli soldier girl
that he sort of teams up with a little
bit I thought she was riveted yeah she
was a good actress and good partner yep
definitely mm-hmm kicking ass and taking
take names yeah of zombies Ryan's
consensus Brad Pitt and zombie thrills
are the main reasons to Sea World War Z
brad pitt and zombie thrills is the main
reasons to sea world war z I guess
that's not groundbreaking in any way but
you know Brad Pitt elevates this movie
and there's there's plenty of good
zombie thrills Jerry's consensus there
are more reasons to Sea World War Z than
I thought there would be there are more
reasons to Sea World War Z the Jerry
thought it would be you know I actually
ended up really enjoying this and i
wasn't sure if i would like it at all
it's a good time it's got a really cool
zombie apocalyptic tone Brad Pitt's good
you know it's compelling I dug it
alright guys thanks for checking out a
review for world war z why don't you go
ahead go to that comment box below and
tell us what is your favorite zombie
movie that you have ever seen and if you
want to check out some more episodes of
reasons to see once you go ahead and
click this link a doodle right here and
going to follow us on our social
networks click the link for facebook
right here and the link for twitter
right here and last but not least if you
want to get updated every time a new
reviewer a video is out so such as
subscribe so i want to mix it up there
like a real yeah well i don't know what
that was in a zombie impression that was
like a yawn yeah how's this Dom beyond I
was like Simon Pegg at the end of Sean
of the day I things on be moving there
there's someone's favorite Charlotte
Dead's an awesome
I could watch a movie like over and over
again I have watched that movie over at
least yeah I think it's gonna be a good
trailer just shaun of the dead hot fuzz
and then groans and mad excited yeah
it's going to be cool these I'm excited
for those tell us below if you're
excited to see those films yeah deck
right hmm ryan right Jerry
you